[Music]
it's the Nikki what up man are you
serious I have someone call me when need
to get out of surgery all right you
should drive out there Rick's been there
for you guys your whole lives the
devil's in the details my friend it work
Atlantic City here we come what we got
Ricky's cancer's back why does it have
to be cancer won't everybody get worried
yeah and that's going to take us right
into the World
[Music]
Series Ricky Nikki the best friend we
never had
my baby's going to be born 6 weeks early
I was born 6 weeks
early I want to know where the hell you
guys were tonight we called every
hospital and there was no record of a
Ricky sikki you know all we did was tell
one lie hundreds and hundreds of times
over many many years if the truth does
come out my marriage is over what if we
hire an actor to play
siki Rock Hard Rod ex-rated rock and
roll impersonated I do a whole act wall
the wall top to bottom jizz jams thanks
for coming out tonight ladies and Gent
gentlemen so horny to be here this is a
really bad
idea oh Jesus I've been cold turkey in
the booze r s nii in the program
remember oh Rod it's not what you think
it is it's just piss I'm a hyper every
time I want you to admit that Ricky St
Nikki does not exist
[Applause]
hey this is Ted summer hay my boss Ted
nice to meet you dig in the suit in the
seedlings man the seedlings the hair
plugs they're new right this is my hair
we're going to lose our
[Music]
job epic night am I right
guys back that's my best friend I was
really taken with your friend steni he's
got brass balls on him that guy that's
why I hired him that's awesome you just
said what did you say just say it one
more time we out of our sight not only
did I miss the birth of my son but I let
some porno Peter Frampton impersonator
snip his and we're done Nikki you are
unbelievable show's over rod it's Ricky
Ricky sikki is it real my job sucked I
had no friends but now I have all those
things are you a fraud sir what you
talking
about we got to get rid of
him every time he tries to make a point
it's like he's smoking invisible dogs
dear God it's true to support now it
looks like I'm cupping the
[Music]
balls
PA